It is April 2nd, day two of 30 of the new
30 days to stop the spread.
I will officially update you daily on the
numbers for the time being.
Official Corona virus case toll as of right
now, 954 thousand.
Yesterday, we had almost 77000 new cases.
Official death toll as of this moment, forty
eight thousand five fifty eight yesterday,
almost 5000 Corona virus deaths in one day.
In the U.S., we officially have more than
two hundred and fifteen thousand cases now,
over five thousand one hundred deaths, more
than 100 deaths yesterday alone for the first
time.
And those numbers will likely worsen.
The latest modeling expects ninety three thousand
five hundred deaths in the United States during
this first wave of infection peaking on April
15th.
That model is adjusted daily based on the
previous day's case and death data.
We have the latest job loss numbers and they
are jarring visually when you see these numbers
on a graph.
It almost
looks like someone made a mistake with the
graph, but it is no mistake.
The number of Americans filing for unemployment
last week was a record breaking 6.6 million
people.
So last week I gave you the prior week's numbers
and those were 3.3 million new jobless claims.
The expected number was 1.6 million.
The actual was 3.3, about double.
Last week, the expectation was 3.7 million.
The real number, almost double, six point
six for eight million new jobless claims.
When you look at the numbers on a graph, it
almost seems like a joke, but it is all too
real.
So to contextualize this, 3.3, followed by
6.6 new jobless claims over the last two weeks
before two weeks ago, the record for new jobless
claims in one week was six hundred ninety
five thousand.
That was back in 1982.
Now, the population was smaller in 1982, roughly
adjusting these numbers for today's population.
Six hundred and ninety five thousand in 1982
would be about a million today.
So again, two weeks ago, 3.3 million new claims
last week, 6.6 million new claims.
To say that this is a historic situation doesn't
even really do it justice.
It will take a very, very long time to recover.
Now, Donald Trump continues to insist it will
be quick, easy, fast, and we will get to a
better point than we were before the pandemic
hit.
There is no doubt that when things start to
open back up, there will be elements that
will recover relatively quickly.
But much of this will not, especially considering
that we're likely medical experts who are
the people we should be listening to.
Medical experts believe we're going to see
a second wave in the fall of this year and
then possibly a third
wave of infection in early 2021.
We may still not have a vaccine at that point
in time.
Now, the follow on problems with the unemployment
claims are huge.
The first problem is that the unemployment
insurance systems, which are administered
at the state level, are failing in many cases
because they're overwhelmed.
Quite simply, universal unemployment insurance
benefits are administered at the state level.
So you've got like the Department of Employment
and Training in Massachusetts, which runs
unemployment insurance here in Massachusetts.
Each state has their own system.
Some states require you to file by phone.
Some are web based.
Some are a combination, whatever.
Widespread reports of whatever system each
state has in place, being simply unable to
keep up phone lines so overloaded that you
can't even get on hold.
In other words, the whole system is full and
you just have to try to call
back at some other point.
So we have more people than ever trying to
file for unemployment benefits.
Meanwhile, the systems can't even keep up.
So of course, if that means some people aren't
getting their money when they deserve it or
when they could otherwise get it, it's early
April.
Right now, rent is due, mortgages are due.
And thus that is going to have follow on effects
like we discussed yesterday on the bonus show,
because people who should be getting unemployment
benefits can't get them.
They can't pay their rent.
They can't pay their mortgages and on and
on and on.
So now the next big number to come out will
be tomorrow, Friday, April 3rd.
We are going to get.
We are expecting the full March unemployment
numbers.
Bear in mind, they probably aren't going to
capture the full scope of the problem because
remember, some
states have only issued stay at home orders
in the last 24 hours.
Some states still have not done that.
I think there's eight or ten states that have
not officially done anything yet, although
maybe at city and town levels, things are
being done.
So the full scope of the.
Problem is not even going to be known with
the April numbers.
Maybe in the May numbers, which will tell
us early May, we will get the April numbers
is what I mean.
We might get a sense of something closer to
the full scope of this.
Now, at the same time, hopefully by the end
of May, we will start to be in some kind of
recovery where some people can start getting
back to work.
But that may not happen.
I don't want to put the cart before the horse
because that may not happen.
Very difficult
time for tens of millions of people in the
United States.